I think first of all we need the
government to sit down with Peugeot and
find out what their requirements are
we've heard some talk about each plant
being judged on its efficiency and
there's no doubt that the plant tells me
report on indeed the plants at Luton are
highly efficient but there are other
things outside of their control the
government are in charge of fir'd today
with business rates procurement supply
chain research and development that
there are all factors in the
competitiveness of a of a plant and I'm
looking for the government to find out
from Persia which ones of those or
indeed are there other things that they
would be keen to for us to do more on
yes being efficient isn't going to be
enough given that Peugeot is looking
right across the piece at all of its
European plants now well simple factors
we don't know what it is that it is
gonna be enough koala can say is that
we've faced these challenges before and
come through them so we've got a good
good history in that regard we've also
got a very big slice of the European
sales market one of the big selling
points for the Vauxhall brand is that
they they're still manufacture in this
country Ellesmere Port imports something
like 75% of its components just how
efficient will it remain should the UK
us everyone expects leave the EU Customs
Union well what we've been looking for
for some time is to get more of the
components manufactured and supplied
directly from UK so the customs union
issue and comply Saban certainly we
don't want any situation moving forward
where tariffs or other impediments are
imposed that would would stop the free
movement of goods of course per show
used to have an operation at writing in
the Midlands they closed that down a
decade ago dojos track record in the UK
give you cause for concern well I think
people are right to point to that but we
should also bear in mind that we've got
new owners and new management now at
Peugeot different people involved
through to the ones who were involved in
writin and everything that we've heard
so far has been positive in terms of
their at their future intentions for the
UK
worthless clearly we need to judge them
on their actions not just their words
though the security the plant looks
reasonably safe until 2021 but obviously
the decision on when the new Astra's
going to be built is made in 2018 when
we're going to be smack in the middle of
negotiations following the triggering of
article 50 how worried I about that well
the timing isn't isn't great but that
that was always going to be the case
regardless of who the owner was
I mean the government have made it very
clear they want to make a successor
brexit for me this is a real test of
whether they're going to deliver on that
carlos tavares has said though that in
some ways having a UK operation provides
an insurance policy in the event of a
heart brexit do you take any comfort
from that well it's an interesting way
of looking at things and I think it's
fair to say that GM have actually
imported a significant proportion of
their continental built vehicles to the
UK in the past and continue to do so so
we're a big part of the market so there
is actually an incentive on both sides
of the channel together get a sensible
deal doesn't it doesn't block any
movement of goods at the end of the day
though the fact that Vauxhall is now
going to be owned by a company which is
part owned by the French government and
whose chief executive has committed to
French and German politicians that he
wants to build a European champion
Vauxhall is not as good a place as it
was when it was owned by GM is it well
this is the challenge we've got as a
country and I think it's a challenge
that were laying down to the government
I know that the the workforce
announcement and loon will do their bit
to make sure the plants are competitive
as possible it's up to the government
then to deal with the political
machinations and make sure that we are
in the best place possible so that that
we continue to manufacture I think it's
a really important part of of UK
industry and once it's gone it's gone so
there can be no underestimation of the
need for the government to act very
strongly on this